[Music]
in favor is a rhythm game where we are
cutting cubes with your sabers that's it
there's a little edge to it it's a very
simple concept what I think make it
really stand out are all those details
we put in all the interactions to me the
beat sabers are special about its
simplicity everybody can get it in a
matter of the seconds you jump in there
is no tutorial not crazy buttons and you
see the sabers it immediately clicks
because humanity has been fighting with
the source for millennia immediately
know that you need to panic cubes from
the small children to the professional
gamers and even to elderly people me
like VR was always something which we
already saw in the movies being a late
eighties or even in the 90s but it was
nothing like what we have right now to
me we are right now is a full experience
with it to controller where you can do
pretty much everything each other is our
recent transition from being mobile
development studio going back to the PC
so it was 2016 and young body is first
we are heading and he has his idea and
he brought me in to support him with
creating a level editor when I bought my
first VR headset I played some VR games
and I thought there is something missing
there and I came up with the idea of
cutting when you hit something you know
this is the point of time where
something happened I decided okay let's
let's try to make a rhythm game where
you are cutting some things and I
started with objects just jumping from
the floor and that obviously didn't work
right so I was experimenting with
movement of the cubes and at one point I
created a new prototype and there's the
movement of the cubes how it's in the
final game which means they're arriving
from the distance and at some point they
jump and you are cutting them in the top
point of their jump which in the final
game most of the people don't notice
this mechanic
there but I think it was essential at
the time because the point where they
are reaching the maximum height is very
clearly defined when the music is the
core you have great responsibility we
all trust each other it's really joy to
work together because you know that you
can have impact on the product and I'm
trying to do like really powerful music
the only way how do you really get into
it is to really experience it having a
coast quest is a really game changer and
I think do the future for us yeah I
think is the future for we are actually
it's a really great headset for the
first time I really see that this can
really open we are to the mainstream
audience this is the future of VR you
just put it in your backpack and you can
take it anywhere with you for example I
always take it with me and I play on the
airport and people look pretty strange
and they don't really get what I'm doing
they'll probably start googling what's
happening we are just in the beginning
with the beat saber I would say we have
so many plans we are releasing 360
degree mode this December which is a
very different experience how to play
the game
oculus glass was something we have been
really really looking forward to with
our game we had this intention to be
with the elements comedian you only from
one direction but this was basically the
limitation of the hollow so once the
oculus quest was introduced all other
possibilities immediately rose up from
our shelf of ideas because without cable
you can freely move but for 4-bit saber
is more about rotation the cubes are not
just coming from the front of you but
they can come from other side it feels
very fresh even though we are working on
it for two years now there is still that
spark and the flame that everybody wants
to make this game as good as possible
because it it's not just about the game
itself but we kind of feel that we are a
little bit responsible for the VR as
well in general because Pete Sabre is
one of the biggest titles this makes us
feel that we are having fun while
creating the game but also it's
beneficial for the whole industry our
number one priority is to make the game
as good as possible without
limits
[Music]